temos aqui o nosso filme antigo de que
nossa máquina para lá em 321 será que é
verdadeiro
o op
o pessoal aqui quem fala darkes muito
bem vindos
é mais um herói é é um estrago sexual
uma pergunta qual é a pergunta como
saber se o diamante e daí
hoje eu fiquei com essa possível também
que muitas coisas para fazer um teste
mas falta uma coisa louca só podia mas
nós não podemos fazer o teste saúde
amanhã então vamos buscar só vamos
buscar a nossa porta secreta da colômbia
para lá não se sabe há muito que não se
à guiné e acho que o pessoal
encontrarmos dia mas aí
[Música]
faltou essa dupla estava em poder do
rock mas não está assim agora eu ia
fazer era para lá ver se o diamante
bruto velho e só pelo que fica muito
grande só o que eu tenho aqui são quatro
botões de punho e tem um dia muito muito
pequeno mas não só
são 42 foi violento e com uma pedrinha
diamante e é superior à demanda que nós
vamos ver se é veterana eu tenho que
chegar e há muitas formas de ver se o
dia mas teve der algumas formas assim
química já outras com peso há outras com
luvas a outras pessoas que conseguem sob
olhar ver cinema e tv da ufpe orgulho
mas nosso pessoal nós nem nós temos aqui
uma máquina que faz um trabalho foi
nosso
esta máquina aqui olha só isso é uma
bolsa do que dentro nós temos com uma
máquina que faz todo o trabalho
olha só o analisador de dimanche o
índice ibex alday monte lushan próximo
leite ou seja não encontra tudo dilma
que é falso e agora que eu estou a pôr a
máquina eu não sei como é que ela
funciona excelente cheguei onde cheguei
mais sobre os diamantes e mesmo assim um
cinto que se podia manter uma das penas
mais duras do planeta terra eu sei que o
diamante encontrado em outra forma esta
forma de forma bruta e depois passa por
todo o processo de apuração a pescar é
esta forma ou formas maior ainda mas
obviamente nunca encontrada assim é
sempre uma pedra que a espanha tipo
deste ano daqui mas depois do diamante
está água cuidado nunca sabe se é
verdadeiro ou não não é isso não está
nesta tarde 29 bola então enquanto
aprende a mexer nisso aí pessoal deixe
muito rica que neste vídeo isso não foi
inscrito no canal israel se que ele não
se lembra se bem em todos os 26 vocês
não deixarem online o youtube não mãe
dos meus filhos pra vocês já aconteceu
isso com dois dos meus vídeos muita
gente diz que não recebeu notificação
então é muito importante mesmo você
estará online então ela já aprende o
sentimento na zona já previsto em cinema
tão ensino não ligou o actor voltou a
prender estes mal está enganado com isso
é porque eles não podemos mexer muito
mas vamos descobrir confirmar esta ponta
da equipe
parece uma caneta ou inglesa acho que
não é só podia mais aguentar muito tempo
altura porque ela é muito resistente
mesmo então eu acho que isso que possuir
um laser mesmo sair não estavam ligar
mais é porque estava rodrigo petronio ou
o sim de uma loja que acendeu uma luz
acendeu uma luz eu vou dar aqui para o
ônibus aqui é que está em espera é que
diz que está pronto é que escutar
diamante e que diz que um dia me falta
então isso é que deve ter 4 12 e doentes
que espera no vazio diz que é preciso
estar ligado aos doentes porque eu
espero realmente não funciona mas eu
acho que ela precisa de algum tempo
porque isto deve mexer com temperatura
então vamos deixar ela crescer enquanto
isso ela tenha que várias outras pedras
que nós vamos fazer também o teste e ver
se este aparelho que realmente funciona
então o que eu tenho aqui eu tenho aqui
dia mas eu tenho aqui um abuso da praia
que é supercomum equipes nem sequer e
valioso mas aproveita uma lei estou no
mar
ei ei eu vi um surfista visitou as
oficinas também ia salvar o surfista
[Música]
vamos testar aqui é o sal de cozinha é
porque eu também o mineral é uma pedra
então acaba por ser a cidade amanhã aí
só 11 tomou outra coisa que nós vamos
também estar é a nossa pedra da
tartaruga mangue é daqui o campo de
golfe que nós temos a lei no jardim é
cercado com estas pedras e eu acho que
isso não sei se vão sair com uma banda
como brilhante que contém muito
brilhante e eu pensei vamos testar aqui
com esta pedra procure a mãe também é
brilhante então vamos lá pessoal pra
ninguém roubar aqui os nossos guimarães
podia manter muito valioso vamos fazer
que o marido intervenção problema
esta será nossa área de testando do que
entrar aqui vai ser analisado ao máximo
nível com o máximo de detalhes pelo cnpe
mas vai pelo conflito este diamante é a
vida né então nós vamos ver agora olha
só eu brilha como um diamante que eu
posso ser mágico também também não
importa porque eu vou ter qualquer
também né é um apenado uma forma um
pouco estranha mas parece ser típico
12345 10 informa do pentágono e eu acho
que é uma forma comum do diamante e é
isso parece estar ser eu acho que é isso
pelo menos quando eu só consigo ver isso
mas eu não sou especialista mas vamos lá
então ligar a nossa máquina e ver o que
acontece não funcionar não é que se ela
não fez nada por que será que tem que
fazer vamos ver todas as possibilidades
ela funciona a pilha eletrônico política
e acho que é importante ter um botão de
ter um sensor aqui ou se novos primeira
está em modo de espera agora se nós
vamos esperar vamos ficar aqui até
quando será alguma coisa assim os cortes
gênio entendimento acho que vai ser um
mês de greve está pronta só isso
analisar o diamante vamos ver outra
pedra qualquer eu vou fazer aqui o teste
com o nosso clube está pronto tem agora
32 1 eu acho que são histórias tudo isso
não acontece nada
não acontece nada ok pessoal acho que
não for diamantes não acontece nada mas
vamos tentar ver por dentro e ver o que
acontece tem esperança que isto é alguma
coisa é porque nunca tive esta máquina
o time recebe a mesma acho que quando
ela pitta é sinal que é falso acho que é
distante com armas e bombas
agora o time espera outra vez eu não sei
por que aconteceu isso aí próximo teste
então enquanto esperamos vai ser com o
nosso amigo de saboroso solta cozinha
grosso é e eu como eu adoro essa um cara
é muito gostoso que já tem dia que não
falem para ver o que acontece em 321 eu
não cheguei lá eu vou ter que ficar aqui
um pouco são 321 vai sair já estou em
contato com o sol não acontece nada pra
cá eu vou tentar isolar aqui uma
pedrinha e fazer um pouco de pressão
acho que vai acontecer alguma coisa o
salto logo eu acho que funciona por
temperatura ou é falso é fácil apitou
falta capital falso não aparece que
nenhuma luz diferente mas eu acho
tipo um alarme é como se fosse falso
mesmo não se desligar isto toca vamos
parar até mesmo tem a máquina que ser é
porque eu acho que ela fique mesmo que
entre na ponta é por isso com sala
ganhou de ponta verde em maceió de cada
vez mais que um dia descobrir aqui como
funciona mas agora que ela está pronta
vamos testar com outro material que
parece ser falso é que esta pedra claro
que é falso não é diante ninguém mas
vamos ver o que tá tão ansioso pela
conquista pinto diamante como foram os
fazer o teste e espero que funcione
porque se pintar também todo o espírito
e não faz sentido porque os
proprietários de veículos e eu não sei
mexer nisso e eu não sei como é que esta
máquina funciona então se não pintar
dilma que vai dar todo errado o vídeo
não faço podem sentir mas eu acho que a
gente estava descobrir sempre perderam
nem agora ela só vê nessa nossa pele
falsa 31 vai cair tudo carlos tudo ok
pessoal estamos em contacto com a pedra
o nosso trecho da praia os seis que
envolve todo o nosso campo do tenente e
não acontece nada e web um brilhante
como diamante e não acontece nada e não
sei o que se passa aqui
méxico - de um bebê que havia então aqui
o nosso texto está a dar certo por agora
o que não estava se tornando a pintura
foi divulgado pessoal está na hora é
hora que nós vamos ver se nós obviamente
é realmente verdadeiro ou não isso eu
fui enganado se eu comprei este guia
muito fofa imagine que eu compreendi
muito fácil ficar muito tempo mas vai
ser verdade vai ser dada agora vamos
começar já que o maior estudo tão
bonitinho mas primeiro vamos ver se o
ouro é verdade não se o ouro pode ser um
potencial de mais neste caso não vai ser
né mas vamos para lá pessoal vão
discursar por testar o nosso puro en 321
vai o uso não só vamos lá estar outra
vez porque não vivem por aí aproximar do
ouro o muito bonita
eu não sei por que dizer isso mas pelos
vistos estão em dia mas vamos agora está
com nosso dilma por votar certo máquina
diz que eu comprei ator temos aqui o
nosso dia mas temos de que nossa máquina
para lá em 321 será que é verdadeiro
op isso é falso
éverton enganando eu acho que o fim da
áea não podia muito caro por isso eu não
estou brincando agora com o intuíto bem
triste
duvido ocorrido visto como esse pessoal
faz uma equipe mais uma vez vejo aí eu
vou pra cima aqui de manhã e em 321 a
uma câmera é difícil mirar a helmand
disse que puder vamos ver agora pedra
por pedra porque tenho quatro botões de
punho então vamos fazer isso trecho
imagina que os vender 14 neste tipo
sofre jackson do dia 10 mas por causa
disso um único game tem cara vamos
começar pelo segundo melhor agora tem
cuca brink o dia mais duro então tudo
isso aqui é muito pequeno como assim 321
vai perder
só comentei o que vocês acham que isto
vai ser falso o visto é comentei por
analisar então só nosso 4.432 um vai
logo que é manco tem essa idéia e agora
já tenho prova como se ensina mesmo
tempo comprei a máquina muito atuei
nesse meio que se funcionar realmente
funciona e agora vou voltar a estar com
sal e ver o que acontece não fizer nada
porque realmente ela funciona é porque
isso pode ter sido um breve para ter
sido assim uma coisa mal feita né e 31
mar e não está no solo
será que aconteceu uma coisa não
acontece nada eu acho que temos a prova
eu vou buscar aqui agora diante de um
dinossauro não faz nada e no diamante é
o mesmo incrível e agora queremos fazer
e vamos resolver isso aqui à nossa porta
do dia mas eu não guardo as coisas todas
direto da vaca for aposentar aqui e veja
diz que vai ficar sim eu estava com que
novos nito outro em 2001 uma mensagem
por ano
o lateral e bruto de mãe tudo só vocês
sabem como é que estão aqui não funciona
comenta embaixo e só se souberem mais
sobre diamantes clique em baixo e
receber mais também é e espero que vocês
tenham gostado aqui o vídeo já sabem
investir muito líquido speedy por eu ser
partilhado com toda a gente disponível
fica o juiz bonitos de e organismo
pretende mesmo só escolher nós aqui no
canal i hubble fiquei no ninho vez que
só fiquem vai até a próxima
[Música]